hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about perfecting your sleep and
energy okay so normally an average
person will go through four 90-minute
sleep cycles through waves from a
superficial sleep to a deep sleep okay
four times through the night the ideal
time to go to bed that aligns with your
hormones would be right around 10:45 to
even up to 11 o'clock at night okay
that's the optimum time to go to sleep
just to catch that first wave if you
miss this first wave sometimes you have
to wait a period of time before you
catch it so you're tired you ever
noticed like when you're really tired at
night and then all of a sudden you stay
up and almost said now you're awake
because you miss the wave okay
so there's little on/off switches in
your brain the back part of the
brainstem that caused you to go to sleep
and then wake up their little hormonal
II controlled on/off switches that work
with a little clock inside your your
brain as well you have a little clock
it's called the suprachiasmatic and yuka
line not that you need to know that but
basically it's a little clock that is
regulated by light and dark so if you're
in your office all day long and you
don't really get outside that can throw
off your sleep cycles now as far as what
happens in the REM sleep REM sleep is
not the deep sleep it's a superficial
sleep that you're almost the wavelength
is almost similar to when you're awake
but you actually are having vivid dreams
that you remember okay
the real rejuvenating sleep is when you
hit the Delta okay down here so this is
what I want to talk about how do you
achieve your full capacity of delta-wave
sleep that's how you generate energy you
don't want to stimulate yourself during
the day you want to get the sleep which
will naturally recharge you just like a
battery so you can have energy during
the day so the Delta wave sleep gives
you the most restorative Repair
regeneration growth immune system repair
of any of the sleep cycles
and also increases a hormone called
growth hormone growth hormone in a child
helps them grow an adult
it's more of an anti-aging because
there's a certain point where you stop
growing it's an anti-aging hormone it's
involved in weight loss repairing a
muscle after exercise so all the benefit
of your exercise occurs through growth
hormone in the Delta wave sleep okay so
if you're not sleeping then you should
use that as an indicator to know that
you shouldn't be exercising too hard
because you're going to over train and
you're not going to repair and you kind
of break things down in fact when you
have insomnia and you don't sleep very
good you can put a lot of stress on your
heart okay on the days you don't sleep
you should do walking and not push it
because you could actually increase your
chance of getting a heart attack so the
other thing I want to talk about is that
you set up several scenarios here you
have a situation where you can't get
this sleep or you wake up at 2:00 in the
middle of the night and can't get back
to sleep and you're fully awake and
you're just like your mind's going
you're probably more awake here than you
are in the morning or the best sleep is
an hour before the alarm clock goes off
or you wake up exhausted or you're up
with your bladder all night long okay so
each one of those situations are a
little bit different
number one can't get the sleep is a
simple mineral deficiency either
deficiency of calcium magnesium or
potassium okay all three of those will
keep you up at night and you just can't
wind down those minerals are the calming
minerals all right wake up at 2:00
that's more of a higher adrenal cortisol
so your adrenals are kind of jacked up
in it and the the cortisol is on a
circadian rhythm and it's altered to the
point where it just kicks in there and
it's almost like it kind of like it
activates cortisol and adrenaline and
wakes you up okay and so you're just
awake ready to go so if that's the case
you need to support the adrenal glands
now if your bladder is making you wake
up every hour then and basically what is
normal is not getting up at all okay
some people say well I don't have a
bladder problem well I get up four three
times a night
well that's not normal you should be
able to go through the whole night that
this right here is an insulin problem
it's insulin resistance I'll put a link
down below because every time that I
have people improve their insulin
dysfunction this symptom goes away if
you ever notice a diabetic they're
peeing excessively right well there's
definitely a connection between blood
sugars and urination and fluid all right
so that should help you with that if
you're waking up exhausted then there's
several other things that we need to do
which I'm going to get into right now
number one I've noticed that when I
consume the right amount of vegetables
which gets the minerals gets all the
other neutral nutrients that I need I
sleep much much better than when I don't
consume enough vegetables so you need to
have between 7 10 cups just a couple
salads it's not hard to do if you're
bloating from your vegetables that's not
going to work either so you're gonna
have to find some vegetables that you
can consume comfortably without bloating
number 2 do not consume excessive
protein large amounts of protein
especially late at night or for dinner
you go for dinner you have this huge
steak and not a good idea because
protein is a stimulant and that will
wake you up prevent sleeping so you want
3 to 6 ounces ok and I would at that
dinner I would have your salad first and
then your protein versus the protein
first and then a side salad
it's just you'll find that you won't use
as much protein if you have your salad
first or your vegetables first too much
caffeine ok do one small cup in the
morning that's what I recommend you
start getting more and it does affect
your sleep quality and even tea will do
that as well so and even chocolate with
it's not caffeine it's another stimulant
that will also keep you up if you have
too much of that small amounts ok of
course sugar-free
snacking at night let's say you have
dinner and then between dinner let's say
at six o'clock till 11:00 you are
snacking popcorn chips peanuts you just
keep eating putting things in your mouth
well that's gonna really raise insulin
it's going to keep you from sleeping as
well because you're gonna feel bloated
so what you want to do for dinner is
have enough fat and vegetable because
this gives you the potassium to be
satisfied so you're not so hungry at
night okay if you're new to my videos
I'll put some links down below but most
of you already know that okay number
five waiting sugar because that raises
insulin and insulin will definitely keep
you up at night as well diabetics do not
sleep well also insulin will deplete
potassium okay it's a little bit deplete
the potassium and then what'll happen
when potassium is low the heart rate
goes higher so try to go to sleep with
your heart rate elevated like in at
ninety or even a hundred you're not
going to sleep so if you can hear your
pulse rate in your ear on your pillow at
night boom boom that means you need more
potassium it could be because you're not
having enough vegetables or your insulin
is too high okay and that comes from
insulin resistance and then so we want
to keep the pulse rate low it's it's
really surprising that some people have
a pulse rate of like 110 normal is 72
but ideally you want an even lower
especially if you want to try to sleep
overtraining here you are you want to
lose weight you start working out you do
the boot camps and that alone can keep
you from sleeping over train and getting
your pulse rate too high that's why I
like interval training where you're
doing as you're getting your pulse rate
up for a short period of time and you're
letting it rest for a longer period of
time when you do CrossFit which is
actually not good for the average person
your recovery times are so short that
it's going to affect your sleeping
because an average person doesn't
recover that fast so you spike your
pulse rate you start resting the pulse
rate comes down a little bit and you
start working again again so you never
allow your
to come fully all the way down and reset
to the bottom level so it's a problem
walking regular walking on the days that
you don't do the high-intensity thing go
off for a long walk get space that is
the absolute best thing for sleep just
getting out there in nature and just
getting your space versus sitting in
office 24/7 okay so and then lastly I
use my sleep aid which has there's two
version one is a vegetarian which
without the glandular adrenal gland
Euler support and the other one is the
regular one with glandular support so
you have your choice in that one but it
doesn't have melatonin it has some
really awesome combinations of certain
herbs and nutrients to really put you in
a nice wonderful sleep to support the
adrenal I take one before I go to bed it
really helped so you might want to try
that anyway thank you so much for
watching put your comments below hey you
probably already subscribed but if you
haven't press this little button down
below and I will keep you updated